et les LR ne sont pas morts et nous le
démontrerons et les LR j'en fais le
serment gagneront l'élection
présidentielle en 2027 ça peut vous
paraître étrange aujourd'hui d'affirmer
ça mais je suis convaincu que le
macronisme ne survivra pas au départ
d'Emmanuel Macron que les Français
mesurent tous les jours la lourdeur d'un
bilan la violence dans la rue il gagne
le désordre dans les ports avec Éric
Zemmour ou marine le penieront dans
l'indépendance une élection
présidentielle c'est la rencontre d'un
homme d'une femme avec le peuple de
France y'a pas besoin d'aller l'Union
des droits
l'élection présidentielle elle ne
nécessite pas d'alliance elle nécessite
de la confiance elle nécessite de la
force de la clarté quand la droite est
droite il n'y a pas besoin d'extrême
droite j'entends tous ceux qui veulent
notre mort qui l'espère on nous allons
les décevoir dans la